schalten gleich in die cdu-zentrale zu
gerd von fall ua 33,5 prozent so die
prognose des zdf gerd wie war die
reaktion
ja man kann sagen dass die mitglieder
und die freunde der cdu hier auf die
tafel geschaut haben es gab dann jubel
aber ich glaube der setzte erst ein als
das fdp ergebnis zu sehen war
denn man muss ist klar sagen die große
koalition bekommt nicht nur der spd
nicht gut sondern auch der cdu
das ist weniger als man hier erhofft
hatte und man muss jetzt aufarbeiten
woran es gelegen hat wir sehen hier noch
mal als der balken nach oben gingen
betretene gesichter und erst dann hat
hier die junge union ein bisschen für
krach gesorgt als das fdp ergebnis kam
aber für union und fdp
die wunsch koalition reicht es ja nicht
das ergebnis selber für die union
enttäuschend der ausgang der wahl aber
so dass das hauptziel erreicht wird
gegen angela merkel gegen die union kann
keine bundesregierung gebildet werden
und es ist so wie wir schon seit tagen
spekuliert haben es scheint wohl nur
eine jamaika koalition und eine große
koalition zu funktionieren aber ob das
die spd will fragen wir mal nach bei
erhard schäfer im willy brandt haus
das ist in diesem moment gerd joachim
sehr sehr schwer vorstellbar die
reaktionen hier als die erste prognose
gekommen ist waren zwischen
zurückhaltend und purem entsetzen das
eigene ergebnis haben aber mehr oder
weniger zur kenntnis genommen wir sind
ja hier im atrium des willy brandt
hauses wo ich behaupte mal mindestens 80
prozent der journalisten im moment
versammelt sind die eigentlichen
anhänger der partei oder auch die
parteimitglieder die sind hier im
durchgang des willy brandt hauses oder
sie sind in den zelten hier jenseits des
willy brandt hauses oder an den
biertischen die reaktion wie gesagt
zwischen zur kenntnisnahme des eigenen
ergebnisses hat man tatsächlich nicht
furchtbar viel erwartet mehr nach den
umfragen der vergangenen wochen
es gab wohl ein leichtes lächeln hat man
dann gesehen hat dass die union auch
nicht viel besser abgeschnitten hat
möglicherweise ja sogar noch mehr
verloren hat als die spd hier das
eigentliche entsetzen bei auf den
gesichtern gab es dann als die zahlen
für die afg bekannt gegeben worden sind
hier wird man jetzt intensiv beraten was
man mit diesem ergebnis anstellen will 1
2 zurück zu gehen die ideen gar nicht
zurück sondern weiter zu es wenn thomsen
bei der fdp da war die stimmung sicher
besser oh ja er hat das was ich danke
schön jetzt wird gerade geburt ich kann
nicht sehen warum aber ich kann dir
sagen als so macht sinn nur die prognose
kam war der jubel hier unbeschreiblich
groß es muss was mit vier jahren
außerparlamentarischer opposition zu tun
gehabt haben und der klatsche die man ja
vor vier jahren bekommen hat und
vielleicht auch der himmel die man
damals erhalten hat hier hat man sich
von keinem ergebnis irgendwie der
anderen stören lassen auch nicht da 13
prozent für die afg man hat ganz auf das
eigene geguckt oder auch die neuen der
grünen erklärter gegner der fdp hat man
ganz auf das eigene ergebnis geguckt hat
schon vorher abgezählt hat sich gefreut
weil man geahnt hat vielleicht auch
gewusst hat es wird ein sehr gutes
ergebnis und man waren offenbar sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr zufrieden mit zehn
prozent was ja auch bedeutet dass man
ein weiteres ziel nicht erreicht hat
nämlich dritte drittstärkste politische
kraft zu werden sie haben schon gesagt
erhard scherfer jamaika ist möglich oder
auch die attacke von kalla und
jetzt schwarz wohl nicht fragen wir mal
im weiteren verlauf des abends dann mal
hier bei der fdp was das für die fdp
bedeuten kann jetzt aber geben wir
erstmal weiter zur afg und zu alexander
kenne ja hier bei der af.de ist
natürlich das ergebnis
[Applaus]
ja das war jetzt leider ein akustischer
will kontakt liebe zuschauer hier bei
der afg ist natürlich der teufel los die
stimmung ist prächtig die partei ist
hochzufrieden mit 13 13,5 prozent an der
hochrechnung nach der prognose um 18 uhr
hier ist es unglaublich laut man
versteht kaum sein eigenes wort man hat
hier um 18 uhr den countdown der letzten
zehn sekunden mitgezählt und ein
unglaublicher lärm dann ein jubel als es
mit den 13 prozent benzin um 13,5
prozent für die afg hier über die sender
gegen spontan wurde das deutschland lied
angestimmt die deutsche nationalhymne
um gleich nachfragen den wind aus den
segeln zu nehmen
die dritte strophe und jetzt spricht
gerade alexander gauland der einer der
beiden spitzenkandidaten der afd die
hier natürlich jetzt aus dem häuschen
ist begeistert ist über dieses ergebnis
13,5 prozent etwas weniger als man
vielleicht im laufe des tages heute
gerechnet hat aber diese 13,5 prozent
machen die afd eindeutig zur
drittstärksten partei ja und zunächst
mal mit diesen stimmungs eindruck hier
aus berlin vom alexanderplatz weiter zur
partei die linke zur constantia platz
gibt
[Applaus]
bei den linken ist gerade applaus der
applaus ist deswegen
wie wir gerade so laut geklatscht und
auch die schuld weil matthias höhn der
bundesgeschäftsführer und
wahlkampfleiter gesamtheit fielen hier
abnahm und zwar nicht die zehn prozent
marke geknackt wir uns vorgenommen haben
aber wir werden dem bundestag das sein
was wir erreicht haben
das ist nämlich noch die drittstärkste
kraft geworden aber wir sind auf jeden
fall im bundestag angehört die sich am
allerstärksten gegen die iphone stellt
damit ist der ton gesetzt hier bei den
linken die laute emotion waren die
bunten vor als das ergeben muss für die
eifel bekannt wurde er als die ersten
prognosen
gezeigt wurden natürlich auch platz
schon auf zufriedenheit über das
ergebnis der linken 9 prozent das ist in
ordnung wie gesagt sehr potent hätte man
sich gewünscht und auch leer
aber ist es auch immerhin das zweitbeste
ergebnis in gelegenen orten sie bisher
eingefahren
die stimmung ist soweit sage ich ganz
gut die prominenz ist bereits da ist im
raum wie sahra wagenknecht fata morgana
von jay mitgebrachter gab es großen
applaus als das auch für mich vor die
wir versuchen uns zu verstimmungen
fragen und geben sie weiter
die grünen sind dafür da constanze und
hier berlin-neukölln folgend lager ist
jetzt tatsächlich volles haus das kann
sie gut hinter mir sehen die kamera
aufzieht und es ist ein haus mit
stimmung die frage wie der eingangs
gestellt haben am nachmittag ob es eine
party wird die kann man jetzt
uneingeschränkt mit ja beantworten wenn
man 1,1 prozent zulegt nach einem
wahlkampf für den man selbst durchaus
als durchwachsen betrachtet hat und er
einige schlitten bereit gehalten hat man
denke nur an die wahlen zum beispiel im
frühjahr saarland als man da aus dem
landtag geflogen ist und hat gesagt das
wird nicht ganz einfach nach voller
demut in diesen abend rein und der jubel
dann wirklich ohrenbetäubend
relativ laute an dieser alten brauerei
und es gab noch eine zweite sehr
emotionale meinungsäußerung dass marty
im ergebnis auf das ist die afg hier in
der prognose muss man sagen
eingefahren hat und was dort vom
produziert wurde das gibt für die grünes
wunder sich einen ganz klaren auftrag
es gibt ein demokratischen auftrag sich
damals also damit
auszutauschen und damit vor allen dingen
die den mathe zu suchen dies hier der
eindruck aus berlin und köln und damit
weiter nach münchen zur csu
woran auch nicht recht zufrieden sein
kann steht machen
betretenes betretene gesichter bei der
csu in münchen
die prognose lag bei 47 und nun hat die
csu 38 prozent eingefahren das ist ein
herber verlust
die ard laut den prognosen um 1 9% hat
hier in bayern zwölf prozent also da
werden sicherlich jetzt ein paar
diskussionen losgetreten bezüglich des
wahlkampfs ziel auch von horst seehofer
wir haben bisher noch keine reaktion
anfangen können aber wir warten
sicherlich jetzt auf die ersten
reaktionen der csu auf dieses
wahlergebnis gespannt kann natürlich
sein auf die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
jahre jamaika gleich die große koalition
ist also die regierungs die
koalitionsverhandlungen für die csu
werden so dass so ziemlich schwierig und
wenn man später noch mal damit zurück
nach bonn